all right know what to do at this point
so I just like try to catch it but it
didn't back away from that same time
doing my job and then I just open my
eyes I'm like oh we don't have the ball
[Music]
Brandon Bostic how you doing bro I'm
good man with you
yeah man how's life been treating
outside of football it's been great you
know just training kids trying to stay
involved in the game stuff like this so
was last time play pool okay so Brandon
would Tom with the playoffs and
obviously doing your time of the Green
Bay Packers you're going to the NFC
Championship game how different is that
experience in Seattle during a playoff
game compared to playing them on a
regular season game that's when a lot of
stadium so imagine trying to play that
imagine trying to hear the quarterback
calling out these signals imagine I hear
the coaches like you laser focus your
game plan is just you so locked in you
know I mean you gotta be on your A game
to win there and that's what was at that
time what do you remember from that
first half I'll just memorize just
dominate and just oh it's good like it
we ride high like things is really going
to vote we 16-under to keep their foot
on my throat in this game and we get
ready for the Super Bowl so we got fast
forward now two minutes left
Russell Wilson scores a touchdown 1914
Packers are up yeah they're coming up
for the onside kick
what was your role on the onside kick
and football have like L means left so
I'll have one two three four like the
fourth guy hansol L fourth my gotta have
the buck that guy you're standing there
what do you recall from that play that's
the first time I live I've ever gonna
live on side kick so like you know he
kicked the ball and I'm just at that
time like okay I got my guy by the same
time my reaction kick game I'll just see
you ball get ball but not in your job so
I'm kind of in-between blocking and
jumping at the same time so I'm like I
ain't know what to do at this point so I
just like try to catch it but then back
away from that same time doing my job
and then I just open my eyes I'm like oh
we don't have the ball I just remember
them screaming they had the ball my damn
I'm walking back to the sideline people
are like what the [ __ ] you don't like he
puts block him out oh you know what I
don't think I've ever said some I just
like when it's out on the bench with my
head down I'll never forget like I
Google myself I don't see what like what
people saying
always see that picture of me just like
he said the convention my head on like
Dan I was a low point in my life
football is a momentum game so one sabu
pretty much blew the game the minimum
was all inside the stadium that that
allows it could be at this point we just
stuck on my play we couldn't really get
over it so just everything just fell
down from there I feel like I was the
reason he lost but at the same time
there's a lot of game left use to the
warning so I don't know it just I still
struggle with a date I'm like to have
what you know what we could have been
but I'll try not to think like that I
try living the present that's in there
games over Packers lose what's going on
the locker room oh yeah I remember
actually crying at this point in my damn
like I don't even know like what I even
do like I never really faced adversity
like this is only a small-town kid you
know I reached my dreams is growing up
everything's made a couple bumps in the
road but everything was so sweet like
just getting there I think that was the
first time I actually like Dan hey I was
just overwhelmed I just remember going
back on the plane hoodie are like I'm
nobody gonna see me so I'll just sneak
on the back of the plane phones one of
my mom's calling me like I'm like I'm
not dealing with anybody so I'm not
talking anybody this point I just
isolate myself you so your phone all the
text messages all the phone calls you
just put on my phone my like crash like
just getting so many social media like
Instagram Facebook this text messages
like death threats from a football game
I'm getting the races I'm getting all
this crazy stuff like even it got to a
point where my agent reached out to me
like do you hunt like a person is
security girl I'm like not like wow I'm
good the next morning we had a team
meeting though so
all teams have like a exit interviews
they call it every player talks to the
coach so I get there and it's Mike
McCarthy my hey what's up like still got
my hoodie on for the night before like
did you change anything I'm gonna sleep
that night he's like you had a good year
Bob you need to work on this work on
that so I'm like how do you feel like
I'm gonna be here next year
he said yeah like I like you like you
have potential like you wanna topside
and we look forward to having something
okay cool I felt I felt good I was first
time someone good said something to my
okay cool my coach feels good about me
I'm good next year I can just no just go
train and I'll make the team next year
I'm good so that was good for me at the
time all season we all go to all my boys
go to Miami we party just non-stop just
we pardon the coke but were you party I
was partying just to get away from it I
got
hoping so I was just oh no I think I was
depressed for sure depressed but oh no I
growing up in South Carolina there's no
like just suck it up but you can't
really show your feelings or show any
weaknesses you know so I just party
that's my thing go to Houston party I
got a call from a Green Bay non-aligned
who's calling me from Green Bay I'm
wasted like hung over he's like this is
a la wolf the personnel guy something
was so he's like no I think we had a
talking I think me gonna really see I'm
like okay good my agent calls me like he
had the fax is gonna release I'm like I
just talked to Mike McCarthy he said I
was good like what's they know are they
gonna release you I'm like are you
serious yeah so I got released I'm going
back on the plane from Houston to
Houston to Green Bay I just got cut I'm
gonna get on my stuff and then I see my
McCarthy I'm like yeah that's crazy like
he's on the plane he's on the plant
going back to Green Bay waiting on the
uber is crazy standing right beside me
I'm like they're like you have nothing
to say like he didn't talk to you at all
we're talking at all like man man like
nothing to say so then I go like can't
myself and I was into that have you ever
felt that that kind of depression before
like the more mature at Maidan I really
was depressed like I was at the dark
time of my life like no one no one loved
me everyone hates me like whatever I did
was wrong like everyone like I remember
just going to the Minnesota they they
saw me something I'm going there so I
just remember going there we had
practice first Ryan I dropped the ball
my god am I still like she always games
the last place or the next place I'm
gonna feel this with the Vikings I
dropped the ball on my damn way this is
terrible at that time I'm still
depressed like I'm partying it went
Arizona just partying just going crazy
not really focusing on football so
that's what I feel like I need to like
get serious like my career gonna be over
so they're not just like refocused I
went back to the basics just what got me
there like my mentality from South
Carolina like I gotta make a play so I
had to like refocus on that and just
find myself again what you learn about
yourself yeah I learned so I'm still
around to this day just like how to face
stuff and just like how to respond like
now like nothing I feel like I'm
bulletproof like nothing like whatever
happens to me I know how to handle it
have you ever talked or seen Aaron
Rodgers since that play oh yeah actually
I saw him in LA just on memory 2015-16
just walking down Hollywood I'm like
well sir Aaron Rodgers office I didn't
see a good like what's up man how's it
going just talking to me he's like hey
like I really appreciate you know what
all you did for us like that play it's a
big play by understanding like f.lux
like that so I just said to him
personally man to man like man I'm sorry
you know I feel like I let you down what
would it mean like it's a package making
suppose it would mean everything to me
bro like oh I might even go so that's
one the pockets win the Superbowl so
they can get off my back so I'm like all
these Instagram and uh Twitter messages
thanks for kicking it with us subscribe
to be our to check out more dope videos
like this one